look at this baby I can't new cooker no
no no gir there's a new mini meatball on
the Jersey Shore Nicole Polizzi aka
Snooki gave birth to her third child
with hubby Jionni a baby boy named
Angelo James the itty bitty bundle of
joy joins four-year-old sister Giovanna
and six-year-old brother Lorenzo
but before Snooki got pregnant for the
third time she told ET she was ready to
become a mom all over again when do you
think you'll have another baby and she
wasn't kidding just three months later
Snooki revealed that she was expecting
on Instagram sharing a series of pics of
her kiddos holding up the ultrasounds
the 31 year olds captioned the sweet
post what I'm thankful for this
Thanksgiving today is a special day
because it's my reveal party just a few
weeks later Snooki shared the sex of her
baby with fans in a video she posted to
YouTube that's little Lorenzo helping
his mom and dad make the announcement by
hitting a baseball full of blue powder
and it's a good thing she gave her kids
a baby brother just check out what they
had to say when Snooki asked them about
the sex of baby number three before the
big reveal Gigi what do you think we're
having a boy what if it's a girl you're
gonna be mad well that's dramatic
[Music]